bienvenue dans ce cours sur la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques, je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis le directeur technique de l'éducation
chez IBM Quantum. C'est la neuvième leçon de la série et la première leçon de la troisième unité, qui porte sur la formulation générale
de l'information quantique. Jusqu'à présent, nous avons utilisé la formulation simplifiée de
l'information quantique, où les états quantiques sont représentés par des vecteurs complexes ayant une norme euclidienne égale à
un. En revanche, dans la formulation générale de l'information quantique, les états quantiques sont représentés par
des matrices d'un certain type appelées matrices densité. Cette première leçon de l'unité se concentre spécifiquement sur les matrices densité
et on verra ce qu'elles sont et comment elles fonctionnent au fil de la leçon. Les matrices densité sont extrêmement
utiles et elles offrent divers avantages dont on parlera. Elles nous permettent de représenter une
classe d'états plus large que ce que les vecteurs d'état quantique peuvent représenter, notamment des états de systèmes affectés par du bruit par exemple, ainsi que des
sélections aléatoires d'états quantiques. On va aussi examiner la sphère de Bloch, qui nous offre une façon
géométrique très simple et agréable de penser aux états d'un qubit, et on verra comment elle se connecte aux matrices densité d'une
façon assez remarquable via les matrices de Pauli. Enfin, on parlera des matrices densité dans le contexte de systèmes multiples
et en particulier, on verra comment elles nous permettent de décrire les états quantiques de systèmes vus de façon isolée, même quand
ils sont corrélés avec d'autres systèmes, y compris la possibilité qu'ils soient intriqués avec d'autres systèmes. C'est une chose importante à pouvoir
faire et ce n'est pas facile à réaliser dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information quantique. Voici un aperçu de la
leçon. On commencera par les bases des matrices densité, incluant les définitions pertinentes et quelques exemples, et on
parlera aussi de leur connexion avec les vecteurs d'état quantique. On parlera ensuite des combinaisons convexes de matrices densité, ou en
d'autres termes, ce qui se passe quand on prend des moyennes pondérées de matrices densité. On commencera par un exemple spécifique
de l'état dit complètement mélangé. On verra comment les états probabilistes classiques peuvent être vus comme
des cas spéciaux de matrices densité et on parlera de la façon dont le théorème spectral de l'algèbre linéaire entre en jeu dans
ce contexte. La troisième partie de la leçon porte sur la sphère de Bloch, qui offre une façon géométrique de voir les états d'un
qubit unique, comme mentionné au début de la leçon. Dans la quatrième partie de la leçon, on parlera de la façon dont les matrices densité fonctionnent pour plusieurs
systèmes. On parlera des états produits et des états corrélés de différentes sortes, notamment les états intriqués, ainsi que
la notion d'état réduit, qui est une description par matrice densité de l'état d'une partie isolée d'un système composé
pouvant être calculée à l'aide d'une opération appelée trace partielle. Avant d'aborder le contenu technique de la leçon elle-même,
il convient de prendre quelques instants pour motiver l'utilisation des matrices densité. En utilisant la formulation simplifiée
de l'information quantique, qui ne fait pas intervenir les matrices densité, on est capable de décrire des algorithmes quantiques comme
l'algorithme de factorisation de Shor par exemple, sans aucune difficulté. Alors pourquoi se donner la peine d'utiliser les matrices densité
ou cette formulation générale de l'information quantique ? Eh bien, il y a plusieurs raisons. Premièrement, les matrices densité
représentent une classe d'états quantiques plus large que les vecteurs d'état quantique, notamment des états quantiques où on a de l'incertitude ou
de l'aléatoire. C'est important quand on veut modéliser les effets du bruit sur les calculs quantiques par
exemple. Deuxièmement, en utilisant les matrices densité, on peut décrire les états quantiques de parties isolées de systèmes composés, comme
les états de systèmes intriqués avec d'autres systèmes qu'on choisit momentanément d'ignorer, comme mentionné au début de
la leçon. Ce n'est pas facile ou naturel à faire dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information
quantique. Une troisième raison est que quand on utilise les matrices densité, l'information classique émerge comme un
cas spécial. Ainsi, au lieu d'avoir ce qui est essentiellement une analogie entre les états probabilistes et les opérations d'un côté
et les vecteurs d'état quantique et les opérations unitaires de l'autre côté, on a l'information quantique et classique
décrites ensemble dans un seul cadre mathématique, ce qui est pratiquement essentiel à l'étude mathématique
de l'information quantique. Donc si tu es sérieux dans ta compréhension de l'information quantique à un niveau mathématique, il est fortement
recommandé que tu apprennes les matrices densité. Commençons par la définition des matrices
densité. Pour les besoins de la définition, supposons que X est un système et que sigma est son ensemble d'états classiques, et rappelle-toi que
lorsqu'on utilise cette terminologie, notre hypothèse est que Sigma est fini et non vide, et comme toujours, on pourrait choisir
des noms différents si on le voulait. Une matrice densité décrivant un état du système X est une matrice ayant des entrées de
nombres complexes dont les lignes et les colonnes ont été mises en correspondance avec son ensemble d'états classiques, et pour être clair,
c'est la même correspondance pour les lignes et les colonnes simultanément. Cela signifie que les matrices
densité sont toujours des matrices carrées, et en plus d'être carrées, il y a quelques conditions qui doivent être
satisfaites et on y reviendra bientôt. Les gens utilisent généralement certaines lettres grecques minuscules pour nommer les matrices
densité. Rho est souvent le premier choix, et d'autres choix courants incluent sigma minuscule et tau, qui sont montrés
à l'écran. C'est juste une convention, mais comme d'habitude, ce genre de conventions est utile parce qu'elles rendent les choses plus
facilement reconnaissables. Parlons maintenant des conditions ou des exigences que les matrices densité doivent satisfaire pour être
des matrices densité valides. Il y en a deux, et ce que je vais faire, c'est d'abord simplement les lister
puis les expliquer plus en détail. La première condition est que les matrices
densité doivent avoir une trace unitaire, c'est-à-dire une trace égale à un. La deuxième condition est que
les matrices densité doivent être semi-définies positives. Dans les deux cas, on a des façons symboliques concises d'exprimer
ces deux conditions qui apparaissent à l'écran. Maintenant, examinons les deux conditions plus en détail.
La première condition fait référence à la trace, qui est une fonction très importante définie pour toutes les matrices carrées
et c'est simplement la somme des entrées diagonales. Voici une équation qui l'exprime
explicitement. Il y a beaucoup à dire sur la trace et pourquoi elle est importante, mais pour l'instant, observons simplement
une propriété très basique, à savoir que c'est une fonction linéaire. D'autres propriétés de la trace apparaîtront et on les discutera
quand on en aura besoin. Mais pour rester concentré sur les matrices densité, passons à la deuxième exigence, à savoir que
les matrices densité sont semi-définies positives. C'est aussi un concept important qui apparaît dans de nombreux contextes en
WEBVTT
physique, chimie, optimisation, apprentissage automatique et d'autres domaines, et il peut s'exprimer de plusieurs façons différentes mais
équivalentes. Une façon de l'exprimer est de dire qu'une matrice rho est semi-définie positive s'il existe une matrice M
telle que rho est égale à M dagger fois M. Et il s'avère que peu importe si on exige que M elle-même soit une
matrice carrée ou si on abandonne cette restriction. Une autre façon d'exprimer ce que signifie pour une matrice rho d'être semi-définie
positive est de dire que rho est hermitienne, ce qui signifie qu'elle est égale à sa propre transposée conjuguée, et que toutes
ses valeurs propres sont des nombres réels non négatifs. En général, les matrices hermitiennes ne peuvent
avoir que des valeurs propres réelles, mais elles peuvent être négatives. Mais si on ajoute la restriction supplémentaire qu'aucune des
valeurs propres ne peut être négative, on obtient les matrices semi-définies positives. D'ailleurs, si on te donne
une matrice et que tu veux savoir si elle est semi-définie positive, tu peux le déterminer en utilisant cette caractérisation. C'est assez facile de
vérifier si une matrice est hermitienne, c'est quelque chose qu'on peut voir à l'œil nu. C'est plus difficile de calculer
les valeurs propres, mais c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas trop difficile à faire avec un ordinateur car il existe des algorithmes très efficaces pour le
faire. La dernière caractérisation que je mentionnerai, bien qu'il en existe d'autres, est que pour tout vecteur colonne s ayant
un nombre d'entrées qui correspond au nombre de lignes et de colonnes de rho, l'inégalité montrée à l'
écran est vraie. En d'autres termes, bra s fois rho fois ket s doit être un nombre réel non
négatif. Ce n'est pas évident, soit dit en passant, que ces caractérisations sont toutes équivalentes, mais c'est le cas. Notons explicitement que la
notation qu'on utilise couramment pour indiquer qu'une matrice rho est semi-définie positive ressemble à rho supérieur
ou égal à zéro, mais ce n'est qu'une notation abrégée et ça ne signifie pas littéralement que rho est supérieure ou égale à
zéro. Rho est une matrice, donc ça n'aurait pas de sens. Et ça ne signifie pas
que chacune des entrées de rho est supérieure ou égale à zéro. En particulier, il existe des matrices
semi-définies positives dont les entrées ne sont pas toutes non négatives, et il existe des matrices dont les entrées sont toutes non
négatives mais qui ne sont pas semi-définies positives. L'idée derrière la notation est que les matrices semi-définies
positives sont comme des analogues matriciels des nombres réels non négatifs, mais ce n'est qu'une notation et ce qu'elle signifie est
précisément ce qu'on a déjà discuté. Maintenant, regardons quelques exemples, en commençant par un exemple de
matrice semi-définie positive. En fait, il est assez facile de générer aléatoirement un exemple de
matrice semi-définie positive en choisissant simplement une matrice M arbitrairement et en calculant M dagger fois
M. Par exemple, voici une matrice M qui n'est pas particulièrement spéciale. En fait,
j'ai généré aléatoirement cette matrice en choisissant indépendamment les parties réelles et imaginaires des entrées comme des entiers entre moins 9 et plus
9. Donc tout motif ou structure ici est purement coïncidentel. En multipliant la
transposée conjuguée de M par M, on obtient cette matrice ici, qui est donc semi-définie
positive. Bien sûr, il y a une limite à l'aperçu qu'on peut tirer d'un exemple aléatoire, mais il présente certaines
caractéristiques communes aux matrices semi-définies positives plus généralement. En particulier, on remarquera
que les entrées diagonales, c'est-à-dire celles le long de la ligne allant du coin supérieur gauche au coin inférieur droit, sont toutes des nombres réels non négatifs.
De plus, les entrées hors diagonale ne sont en quelque sorte pas trop grandes par rapport aux entrées diagonales correspondantes,
c'est-à-dire celle dans la même ligne et celle dans la même colonne que l'entrée hors diagonale qu'on examine.
Il y a cependant plus à dire, et il est important de reconnaître que le fait d'être semi-définie positive est une
propriété d'une matrice dans son ensemble et pas seulement une condition sur les entrées individuelles. C'est donc un exemple de
matrice semi-définie positive, et tu peux très facilement générer d'autres exemples par une
méthodologie similaire. Maintenant, regardons quelques exemples de matrices densité où, en plus de la condition semi-définie positive, on a aussi que la trace est
égale à un. Voici quelques exemples de matrices densité 2x2. La trace est égale à
un dans les quatre cas, et on peut aussi voir que ce sont des matrices hermitiennes. Donc en utilisant la deuxième caractérisation des
matrices semi-définies positives de tout à l'heure, il reste seulement à vérifier que les valeurs propres sont toutes non négatives.
Je te laisse le vérifier si tu le souhaites. Pour les matrices 2x2, il n'est pas trop difficile de calculer les valeurs propres à la main,
mais tu peux aussi demander à un ordinateur de le faire. Par exemple, tu peux utiliser la fonction eigvals dans le package d'algèbre linéaire
pour Python. On peut aussi obtenir une matrice densité en prenant simplement une matrice semi-définie positive non nulle
et en la divisant par sa trace. Par exemple, voici la matrice densité qu'on obtient en
divisant l'exemple qu'on a vu il y a quelques instants par sa trace. Cette division par la trace
préservera toujours la propriété semi-définie positive et on obtiendra certainement une matrice ayant une trace égale à un par vertu du fait que
la trace est une fonction linéaire. C'est juste une petite collection d'exemples et on en verra d'autres au fil de
la leçon. Ensuite, prenons quelques instants pour discuter de l'interprétation ou du
sens intuitif des matrices densité. La première chose à reconnaître est que ça peut sembler un peu inhabituel
de représenter l'état d'un système avec une matrice plutôt qu'un vecteur. En revanche, dans la formulation simplifiée
de l'information quantique, on utilise des vecteurs pour représenter les états, tandis que les matrices, spécifiquement les matrices unitaires,
représentent des actions ou des opérations. C'est juste comme ça que les mathématiques fonctionnent, et bien qu'on puisse
toujours penser aux matrices comme décrivant des applications linéaires, on n'associe généralement pas une signification intuitive directe
à l'application linéaire associée à une matrice densité donnée. Cela dit, le fait que
les matrices densité soient bien des matrices s'avère être un aspect d'une importance critique et on le verra
en continuant. Mais pour mentionner brièvement juste un exemple pour l'instant, les valeurs propres d'une matrice densité donnée
s'avèrent être très importantes car elles décrivent la quantité d'aléatoire ou d'incertitude inhérente à l'état
que cette matrice densité décrit. Une autre façon de penser aux matrices densité à un niveau intuitif
se concentre sur les entrées de ces matrices. Rappelle-toi que les lignes et les colonnes des matrices densité sont mises
en correspondance avec les états classiques de quel que soit le système dont on parle. Donc pour chaque entrée, on a un
WEBVTT
état classique correspondant à la ligne de cette entrée et un état classique correspondant à la colonne de cette
entrée. Pour les entrées diagonales, ces deux états classiques sont le même état, et c'est pourquoi les entrées diagonales sont
spéciales. Une façon d'interpréter les entrées diagonales est qu'elles sont des probabilités, et spécifiquement ce sont
les probabilités que l'état classique correspondant apparaîtrait si on effectuait une mesure dans la base standard
sur le système dont on décrit l'état quantique. Pour les entrées hors diagonale en revanche, on a un état classique correspondant à la ligne
de cette entrée et un état classique différent correspondant à la colonne de cette entrée. De façon très informelle,
ces entrées décrivent le degré auquel ces deux états classiques sont en superposition quantique, ainsi que la
phase relative entre eux. Ça aura peut-être plus de sens au fil de la leçon quand on regardera de plus
près des exemples spécifiques. Les détails ne sont peut-être pas clairs à ce stade, mais s'il te plaît, ne t'en préoccupe pas.
C'est assez informel et c'est juste une idée intuitive à garder à l'esprit.
Ensuite, on va examiner le lien entre les matrices densité et les vecteurs d'état quantique, qui sont des vecteurs colonnes
ayant une norme euclidienne égale à un. Juste pour rappeler la définition mathématique : supposons qu'on ait un
vecteur d'état quantique psi qui représente l'état d'un système particulier. La matrice densité qui représente le même
état quantique est donnée par ket psi fois bra psi, comme montré ici à l'écran. Pour être clair, les indices de psi
correspondent d'une certaine façon aux états classiques de quel que soit le système dont on parle, et c'est exactement la même correspondance qu'on a entre
les lignes et les colonnes de notre matrice densité et les états classiques du système. Si on imagine qu'il y a n
états classiques du système et qu'on pense aux vecteurs colonnes et lignes comme des matrices, alors ket psi est une matrice N par 1
et bra psi est une matrice 1 par N. Donc quand on effectue la multiplication, on obtient une matrice N par N.
Ce sera toujours une matrice semi-définie positive juste par sa forme, et elle aura aussi une trace égale
à un grâce au fait que psi est un vecteur unitaire, et on verra ça plus en détail
bientôt. Les états quantiques représentés par des matrices densité de cette forme sont appelés états
purs. Voici quelques exemples. Commençons par cet état
ici, qui ressemble un peu à un état plus, sauf que l'entrée correspondant à l'état classique un est
imaginaire. Si on calcule la transposée conjuguée, on va obtenir un signe moins parce que le conjugué complexe de i est
moins i. Et si on fait la multiplication, on obtiendra la matrice montrée ici à l'écran. Elle est hermitienne, comme on peut
le voir immédiatement juste en la regardant, et il se trouve qu'elle a une valeur propre égale à un et une valeur propre égale à
zéro. Donc elle est semi-définie positive et sa trace est égale à un. C'est donc bien une matrice densité, comme
attendu. On peut calculer les matrices densité correspondant aux bases standard et plus/moins de façon similaire, et ces matrices densité
sont montrées ici. Et voici un autre exemple de vecteur d'état quantique, qui était apparu
tout au début dans la première leçon de la série. Si on calcule la transposée conjuguée puis qu'on multiplie,
on obtiendra la matrice densité montrée ici. Encore une fois, elle est hermitienne et a une
trace égale à un. Et si tu calcules les valeurs propres, tu trouveras qu'elle a encore une valeur propre égale à un et une
valeur propre égale à zéro. D'ailleurs, c'est une caractéristique commune à tous les états purs : ils ont toujours une valeur propre
égale à un et les autres valeurs propres sont toutes zéro. En général, pour un vecteur d'état quantique complètement arbitraire
psi avec n'importe quel nombre d'entrées, si on multiplie ket psi par bra psi, on obtiendra une
matrice densité qui ressemble à ça. Remarque en particulier que les entrées diagonales sont toujours l'une des entrées
de psi multipliée par son propre conjugué complexe, qu'on peut aussi exprimer comme la valeur absolue au carré de cette entrée. C'est
une façon de voir que la trace sera toujours égale à un. C'est aussi cohérent avec la remarque que j'ai faite plus tôt dans la leçon sur les
entrées diagonales d'une matrice densité nous indiquant quelles seraient les probabilités de voir chaque état classique possible
si on effectuait une mesure dans la base standard. Et une dernière remarque :
il n'y a aucun problème concernant les phases globales pour les matrices densité. Deux états quantiques sont identiques si et seulement si leurs matrices
densité sont égales. Supposons en particulier qu'on ait deux vecteurs d'état quantique psi et phi qui
sont équivalents à une phase globale près, ce qui signifie qu'on peut exprimer l'un d'eux, disons phi, comme l'autre fois
un certain nombre complexe sur le cercle unité. Si on calcule la représentation en matrice densité de phi, alors ce qu'on
trouvera est que le facteur de phase globale est multiplié par son propre conjugué complexe, ce qui nous donne un. Donc il
disparaît effectivement et on se retrouve avec exactement la même matrice densité qu'on obtient de psi. C'est donc un
petit bonus agréable. Et plus généralement, il n'y a aucun problème concernant l'équivalence à une phase globale près quand on
travaille avec des matrices densité. C'est juste une dégénérescence qui existe quand on utilise des vecteurs d'état quantique plutôt que
des matrices densité pour représenter les états quantiques. Les matrices densité possèdent une propriété clé, à savoir que les combinaisons convexes
de matrices densité représentent des sélections probabilistes ou aléatoires d'états
quantiques. Une autre façon de le dire est que les matrices densité peuvent être moyennées ensemble de façon significative, ce qui
n'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut faire avec les vecteurs d'état quantique. Pour expliquer ça plus en détail, commençons par la situation dans laquelle
on a deux matrices densité rho et sigma qui représentent des états quantiques d'un certain système. Imaginons que le
système est préparé dans l'état rho avec une probabilité p, pour un certain choix de p entre zéro et un, et sinon le
système est préparé dans l'état sigma. Par exemple, peut-être que p est 1/2, donc on
pourrait imaginer que quelqu'un lance une pièce équilibrée et si c'est pile, il effectue un processus qui laisse le système dans
l'état rho, et sinon, si la pièce tombe sur face, il effectue un processus différent qui laisse le système dans l'
état sigma. La question maintenant est : quel est l'état du système ? Et pour être clair,
on s'intéresse à l'état du système en isolation, sans tenir compte d'autres informations qui pourraient exister sur
quelle préparation a été effectuée. Par exemple, imaginons qu'on n'a pas accès à la pièce ou à la
mémoire de quiconque a effectué la préparation de l'état. Et la réponse à cette question est que c'est simplement la moyenne pondérée des deux matrices
WEBVTT
densité : p fois rho plus 1 moins p fois sigma. C'est d'ailleurs complètement
analogue à ce qu'on aurait si rho et sigma n'étaient pas des matrices densité mais plutôt des vecteurs de probabilité
représentant des états probabilistes. Ce n'est donc pas quelque chose de choquant ou de mystérieux, mais plutôt quelque chose
qui est peut-être familier de la théorie des probabilités. On fait ce genre de moyenne tout le temps quand on calcule des probabilités et qu'on pense
à des sélections aléatoires classiques. Et le point est que ça fonctionne aussi pour les matrices densité, mais note que ça ne
fonctionne pas pour les vecteurs d'état quantique. C'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut généralement pas faire la moyenne de deux vecteurs d'état
quantique comme ça et espérer obtenir un vecteur d'état quantique valide. Et si tu essaies, tu obtiendras généralement un vecteur qui
n'a pas de norme euclidienne égale à un. Avec les matrices densité cependant, les moyennes pondérées comme ça seront toujours
des matrices densité valides, et plus important encore, la matrice densité qu'on obtient représentera cette sélection aléatoire de
façon significative. Ça se généralise aux sélections aléatoires où il y a plus de deux
alternatives. En particulier, si on a M matrices densité possibles et un vecteur de probabilité à M entrées, une
pour chaque matrice densité, et qu'un système est préparé dans chaque état possible avec la probabilité correspondante,
alors la moyenne pondérée de ces matrices densité décrit l'état résultant du système. Et d'ailleurs, quand
on parle d'une combinaison convexe de matrices densité, c'est ce qu'on entend. Une combinaison convexe est simplement une combinaison linéaire
où les coefficients forment un vecteur de probabilité. Ce sera toujours une matrice
densité, et une façon simple et concise de le dire en termes mathématiques est que l'ensemble de toutes les matrices densité
correspondant à un système donné est un ensemble convexe. Donc si on a, disons, m vecteurs d'état quantique
psi 0 à psi M moins 1, ainsi que des probabilités p 0 à p m moins 1 qui forment collectivement un
vecteur de probabilité, et qu'un système est préparé dans l'état s k avec la probabilité pk pour chaque k, alors
l'état résultant du système est décrit par la matrice densité montrée ici à l'écran. En particulier, on ne fait pas la moyenne
ensemble des vecteurs d'état quantique eux-mêmes, mais plutôt on fait la moyenne ensemble des matrices densité correspondantes.
En général, un état comme celui-ci n'aura pas de représentation comme un seul vecteur d'état
quantique, à moins que quelque chose de trivial ne se passe, comme tous les vecteurs d'état quantique étant équivalents à une phase globale près, ou tous sauf un des
probabilités étant zéro. On n'obtiendra pas un état quantique pur d'un tel processus. On obtiendra plutôt ce qu'on appelle
un état quantique mélangé, où il y a une certaine incertitude inhérente. Regardons un exemple simple.
Supposons qu'on ait un qubit et qu'avec probabilité 1/2, le qubit est préparé dans l'état zéro, et sinon
il est préparé dans l'état plus. Voici la matrice densité qu'on obtient en faisant la moyenne, comme je l'ai
décrit. On calcule les matrices densité correspondant aux deux états possibles, on multiplie par les probabilités correspondantes et on additionne les
résultats. Ce qu'on obtient est bien une matrice densité : elle est hermitienne, sa trace est égale à un,
et si tu calcules les valeurs propres de cette matrice, tu obtiendras deux nombres réels positifs qui sont deux nombres qui devraient probablement t'être familiers
maintenant : cosinus carré de pi sur 8 et sinus carré de pi sur 8, soit environ 0.85 et
0.15. Il n'y a pas de représentation par un seul vecteur d'état quantique de cet état. Ce n'est pas un état pur. Ensuite, on va examiner une
matrice densité particulière qui représente un état quantique d'un seul qubit, connu sous le nom d'état complètement
mélangé. Cet état apparaît fréquemment, il est donc bon d'avoir un nom pour lui. C'est aussi un bon exemple parce qu'il
illustre une caractéristique importante des matrices densité. Il existe en fait un état complètement mélangé défini analogiquement pour tout
système, mais pour l'instant, on va se concentrer sur cet état pour un seul qubit juste pour garder les choses
simples. Supposons qu'on fixe aléatoirement l'état d'un qubit à être soit l'état zéro, soit l'état un, chacun avec
une probabilité égale à 1/2, un peu comme un bit aléatoire uniforme. On peut calculer la représentation en matrice densité de cet
état de la façon habituelle : on prend la moyenne des deux représentations en matrice densité des états. Voici comment
ça se présente sous forme matricielle, et ce qu'on obtient est la matrice identité divisée par
deux. Cet état est connu sous le nom d'état complètement mélangé, et il représente essentiellement une incertitude complète ou maximale
sur un qubit, tout comme un vecteur de probabilité uniforme représente une incertitude maximale dans le
cadre probabiliste classique. En général, pour un système arbitraire, l'état complètement mélangé est l'
état qu'on obtient en choisissant uniformément un état de base standard, et la représentation en matrice densité sera la
matrice identité divisée par la dimension, ou équivalemment le nombre d'états classiques de ce
système. À ce stade, c'est juste de la terminologie, mais si on modifie un peu le réglage, on verra une caractéristique importante des
matrices densité. En particulier, supposons qu'on change la procédure et que
à la place des états de base standard zéro et un, on substitue les états plus et moins. Cette fois, on commence avec l'
expression montrée à l'écran, mais si on fait l'arithmétique, on obtient exactement la même
matrice densité. C'est la matrice identité divisée par deux. Donc c'est le même état qu'avant :
l'état complètement mélangé. Ça, comme on dit, est une fonctionnalité et non un bug. Les deux procédures sont en fait
différentes, mais si tout ce qu'on a c'est le qubit résultant, il n'y a aucun moyen physique de les distinguer,
même dans un sens statistique. Par exemple, si tu effectuais une mesure dans la base standard sur ce qubit
après que la première procédure a été effectuée, tu obtiendrais évidemment le résultat zéro avec probabilité 1/2 et le résultat un avec probabilité 1/2. Mais tu obtiendrais aussi
exactement les mêmes probabilités de résultat pour la deuxième procédure, et la même chose est vraie pour tout autre test que tu pourrais
imaginer, en supposant que tu testes juste le qubit lui-même. En général, les matrices densité ne décrivent pas comment un système a été
préparé ; elles te disent seulement ce qui va se passer si tu fais des choses à ce système à l'avenir, que ce soit en effectuant des
opérations ou des mesures. Et en fait, les matrices densité sont parfaites à cet
égard. Si deux alternatives différentes résultent en la même matrice densité, elles ne peuvent pas être discriminées, même
statistiquement. Mais si les deux matrices densité sont différentes, il y aura un moyen de les discriminer, pas
nécessairement de façon définitive, mais dans un sens statistique. Quand on utilise la formulation générale de l'information
WEBVTT
quantique, l'information classique émerge essentiellement comme un cas spécial, et je vais maintenant expliquer comment ça
fonctionne. Plus précisément, on va voir comment les états probabilistes peuvent être représentés par des matrices
densité. Commençons par les états classiques, en débutant par un exemple simple.
Voici les représentations en matrice densité des états de base standard zéro et un d'un
qubit. On associe ces états aux états classiques 0 et 1, et donc on peut penser à ces matrices densité comme
représentant ces états. C'est très simple, et on peut facilement généraliser
l'exemple. Si on a un système dont l'ensemble d'états classiques est Sigma, alors l'état classique a est représenté par ou
associé à la matrice densité ket a bra a. Cette matrice a un seul un dans l'entrée
diagonale dont la ligne et la colonne correspondent à l'état classique a, et toute autre entrée est
zéro. Les états probabilistes sont représentés par des combinaisons convexes de matrices de cette forme, ce qui est naturel
étant donné ce qu'on sait sur les matrices densité et leur fonctionnement, spécifiquement que les combinaisons convexes de matrices densité représentent des sélections aléatoires ou
probabilistes d'états quantiques. Par exemple, supposons qu'on ait
un système X dont l'ensemble d'états classiques comprend les entiers 0 à n moins 1 pour un certain entier positif n.
Bien sûr, il y a peu ou pas de perte de généralité à supposer que notre ensemble d'états classiques ait cette forme. Si on avait un
ensemble d'états classiques différent, on pourrait simplement renommer les états classiques de cette façon, et il est souvent assez pratique de faire l'hypothèse que nos
ensembles d'états classiques ressemblent à ça, en grande partie parce que ça facilite l'écriture explicite des choses en termes de
vecteurs et de matrices. Supposons qu'on ait un état probabiliste du système X
représenté par un vecteur de probabilité de la façon habituelle. On peut associer cet état probabiliste à une matrice
densité, comme montré à l'écran. On prend la moyenne pondérée des matrices densité correspondant aux
différents états classiques, et ce qu'on obtient est une matrice densité diagonale. En particulier, on voit les probabilités
le long de la diagonale de cette matrice, et toute autre entrée est égale à zéro. Bien sûr, c'est bien une matrice densité,
on s'y attendait, mais on peut aussi le raisonner directement. C'est une matrice hermitienne, sa trace
est égale à un parce que les probabilités somment à un, et dans le cas d'une matrice diagonale, les valeurs propres sont les entrées diagonales
et elles sont toutes non négatives car ce sont des probabilités. Remarque aussi que chaque
matrice densité diagonale, c'est-à-dire celle dont toutes les entrées hors diagonale sont zéro, doit ressembler à ça. Donc en bref,
les états probabilistes peuvent être associés à des matrices densité diagonales. Remarque d'ailleurs que c'est cohérent avec
l'interprétation informelle des entrées des matrices densité que j'ai mentionnée au début de la leçon. En particulier, rien n'est en
superposition quantique ici ; c'est essentiellement juste de l'aléatoire classique, et en conséquence, toutes les entrées hors diagonale
sont zéro. Plus tôt dans cette série, on a discuté du théorème spectral, et on l'a fait
spécifiquement pour les matrices unitaires dans le contexte de l'estimation de phase. Le théorème spectral est plus
général que ça cependant, ce qui signifie qu'il nous dit quelque chose sur une classe de matrices plus large que juste les matrices
unitaires. En particulier, il s'applique à une classe de matrices appelées matrices normales, qui incluent toutes les matrices hermitiennes ainsi
que les matrices unitaires. Ce qu'on va faire maintenant, c'est examiner un énoncé différent de ce théorème, cette fois en se concentrant uniquement sur les
matrices semi-définies positives, puis on verra qu'il nous dit quelque chose de très intéressant et d'une importance critique sur les matrices
densité. Supposons que p soit une matrice semi-définie positive quelconque, ce qui inclut toute matrice densité ainsi que toute
matrice semi-définie positive qui n'a pas de trace égale à un. p est semi-définie positive donc elle doit être
carrée, c'est-à-dire N par N pour un certain choix de N. On va avoir besoin de faire référence à ce nombre N, donc soit N
choisi de façon appropriée, ou une autre façon de dire tout ça est de supposer que p est N par N. Ce que le théorème nous dit dans ce cas est qu'il
doit exister une base orthonormée de vecteurs qu'on nommera psi 0 à psi N moins 1, ainsi que des nombres réels non négatifs
lambda 0 à lambda N moins 1, tels que p peut s'exprimer comme montré
ici à l'écran. En d'autres termes, si on multiplie chaque lambda k par ket psi k fois bra psi k et qu'on
somme sur tous les k de 0 à N moins 1, on obtiendra p. C'est appelée une décomposition
spectrale de p. Chaque lambda k est nécessairement une valeur propre de p et chaque psi k est un vecteur propre normé de p
correspondant à cette valeur propre. Si tu regardes la leçon 7 sur l'estimation de phase, tu trouveras un théorème similaire
pour les matrices unitaires. Là, les valeurs propres sont des nombres complexes sur le cercle unité plutôt que d'être des nombres réels non négatifs,
mais sinon c'est la même idée. Et ce sont vraiment juste deux cas spéciaux d'un théorème plus général appelé
le théorème spectral. Ça ne fonctionne pas pour toute matrice ; il faut que la matrice commute avec sa
propre transposée conjuguée, et c'est ce que ça signifie pour une matrice d'être normale. Mais on a en fait toujours
ça pour les matrices unitaires et les matrices semi-définies positives, et pour les matrices hermitiennes plus généralement, où
on aura toujours des valeurs propres réelles mais pas nécessairement non négatives. C'est donc un énoncé du
théorème spectral pour les matrices semi-définies positives seulement, et voyons maintenant ce qu'il nous dit sur les matrices
densité. Ce qu'il nous dit, c'est que pour une matrice densité N par N arbitraire, on peut toujours exprimer cette matrice comme une combinaison convexe
de N états purs, et de plus, on peut prendre ces N états purs comme étant
orthogonaux. Ça découle assez directement du théorème ainsi que d'un fait de base de l'algèbre linéaire, à savoir que
la somme des valeurs propres de toute matrice est toujours égale à la trace de cette matrice. En d'autres termes, tout ce qu'on fait vraiment,
c'est renommer les valeurs propres p 0 à p N moins 1, puis observer que quand on fait ça et qu'on
rassemble ces valeurs propres dans un vecteur à N dimensions, on obtient nécessairement un vecteur de probabilité parce qu'elles doivent toutes être non négatives et leur somme est égale
à la trace de rho, qui est un parce que rho est une matrice densité. C'est donc assez simple, mais c'est
vraiment fondamental d'un point de vue conceptuel. Ce que ça nous dit, c'est que chaque matrice densité, peu
importe à quel point elle peut sembler compliquée, pourrait résulter de la sélection d'abord d'une base orthonormée de quel que soit le système
dont on parle, puis du choix aléatoire d'un état quantique de cette base selon un choix pour les
WEBVTT
probabilités. Si ce n'est pas immédiatement clair pourquoi c'est intéressant ou important, pas de problème, mais on utilise
ce fait très fréquemment quand on raisonne sur les matrices densité. Et en fait, exprimer une matrice densité donnée
de cette façon est souvent la toute première chose qu'on fait quand on veut la comprendre
mieux. Voici un exemple. Rappelle-toi la matrice densité qu'on a trouvée plus tôt, où on choisissait aléatoirement entre
l'état zéro et l'état plus, chacun avec probabilité 1/2, qui, comme on l'a calculé, a une matrice densité qui
ressemble à ça. L'état zéro et l'état plus ne sont pas orthogonaux, donc ce n'est pas une
décomposition spectrale. Mais si on en calcule une, ce qu'on peut faire avec un ordinateur ou à la main dans un cas comme celui-ci, alors ce qu'on
obtient est cette expression de notre matrice densité, où les valeurs propres sont ces nombres qui continuent d'apparaître et
où les vecteurs propres correspondants peuvent être choisis comme montré ici en bas de l'écran. Et encore une fois, on a déjà vu ces vecteurs, par exemple dans le
contexte du jeu CHSH en Leçon 4. C'est donc intéressant : selon
l'expression originale, cet état est ce qu'on obtient en choisissant uniformément entre deux états : l'état zéro et
l'état plus. Mais en fait, on obtient exactement la même matrice densité en choisissant aléatoirement entre deux états
purs, mais en favorisant très fortement l'un d'eux, environ 85% pour le premier et seulement environ 15% pour
le deuxième. Donc dans un certain sens, il y a en fait moins d'aléatoire inhérent à l'état qu'il n'y paraissait initialement.
Il y a une façon géométrique très agréable de penser et de visualiser les états quantiques d'un seul qubit, connue
sous le nom de sphère de Bloch. Ça ne fonctionne que pour les qubits uniques ; pour les systèmes ayant trois
ou plus d'états classiques, y compris deux qubits ou plus ensemble, ça ne fonctionne plus. Donc c'est assez limité, mais
néanmoins, c'est une excellente façon de penser aux états d'un seul qubit. Ça aurait pu être introduit bien
plus tôt dans la leçon 1 de la série sur les systèmes uniques, mais ce n'est pas vraiment essentiel pour comprendre comment l'information quantique fonctionne, et ça a aussi une
très belle connexion avec les matrices densité. Donc ça s'insère naturellement dans cette leçon. En fait, je vais l'expliquer
d'une façon un peu différente de la façon dont on l'explique peut-être le plus typiquement, en utilisant les matrices densité pour effectivement
la dériver. Donc si tu es déjà familier avec la sphère de Bloch, cette explication sera peut-être un peu différente de la
façon dont tu l'as apprise en premier lieu, mais au final, c'est bien sûr équivalent. On va commencer par penser aux
états purs possibles d'un qubit, d'abord représentés par des vecteurs d'état
quantique. À une phase globale près, tout vecteur d'état quantique d'un qubit peut s'exprimer comme
montré ici à l'écran. Pour être précis, on a deux nombres réels theta et phi, et on va
penser à ces deux nombres comme étant des angles exprimés en radians. Le premier nombre theta est entre 0 et pi, ou équivalemment c'est un
angle entre 0 et 180°. Et le deuxième nombre phi est entre 0 et 2 pi, incluant 0 mais pas 2
pi. Donc c'est n'importe quel angle entre 0 et 360°. L'entrée zéro de notre vecteur est
cosinus de theta sur 2. C'est donc un nombre réel entre 0 et 1, et en particulier il est nécessairement non négatif.
Et l'entrée un de notre vecteur est e à la puissance i fois phi fois le sinus de theta sur 2, et ça peut être
n'importe quel nombre complexe sur ou à l'intérieur du cercle unité complexe. C'est toujours un vecteur unitaire, ou
en d'autres termes c'est un vecteur d'état quantique valide. Et pour n'importe quel vecteur d'état quantique de qubit donné, on peut toujours trouver
un vecteur de cette forme qui est équivalent à ce vecteur à une phase globale près. En particulier, on peut toujours
multiplier le vecteur donné par une phase globale pour rendre l'entrée zéro un nombre réel non négatif, choisir quel que soit le
theta qui nous donne cette entrée, puis choisir phi pour correspondre à l'entrée un. La magnitude de l'entrée un
correspondra toujours nécessairement avec le sinus de theta sur deux par l'hypothèse qu'on a commencé avec un vecteur
unitaire. Maintenant, il n'est pas tout à fait le cas que theta et phi sont uniquement déterminés par quel que soit le vecteur d'état quantique dont on est parti,
mais c'est presque le cas. Il y aura toujours une valeur unique de theta entre zéro et pi qui fonctionne,
et généralement il y a une valeur unique de phi qui fonctionne, mais dans deux cas spéciaux, ce n'est pas vrai. En particulier, si on est parti d'un
état de base standard, alors theta sera soit zéro soit pi, et dans les deux cas, ça ne fait en fait pas de différence ce que phi est,
c'est complètement non pertinent. Quand theta est zéro, le cosinus de theta sur 2 est 1 et le sinus de theta sur 2
est zéro, donc on multiplie e à la puissance i fois phi par zéro, donc ça ne fait aucune différence ce que phi est.
Et si theta est pi, alors cette fois le cosinus est zéro et le sinus est un, donc on a e à la puissance i fois phi fois ket 1, mais ces
vecteurs sont tous équivalents à une phase globale près, donc encore une fois peu importe ce que phi est. Cependant, si theta est strictement
entre zéro et pi, alors il y aura toujours une valeur unique de phi qui fonctionne. D'ailleurs, cette possible
dégénérescence dans la valeur de phi pour les deux cas spéciaux aura tout son sens quand on verra la représentation géométrique dans
juste un instant. Calculons maintenant la matrice densité associée à un vecteur d'état de la forme qu'on vient d'
identifier. C'est donc un état pur d'un qubit. Pour ce faire, on multiplie le vecteur
par sa transposée conjuguée comme d'habitude, et à l'écran se trouve une expression de la matrice qu'on obtient en calculant la
transposée conjuguée et en effectuant la multiplication. Maintenant, tout comme pour toute matrice 2x2,
il y a une façon unique d'obtenir cette matrice en prenant une combinaison linéaire des matrices de Pauli
incluant la matrice identité. En particulier, on peut obtenir cette matrice en choisissant les coefficients des
matrices de Pauli comme montré ici à l'écran. On met un deux au dénominateur parce que ça va rendre
tout bien s'assembler ; rien ne nous force à faire ça, mais on peut et ça va être utile. Mais à part
ce choix cosmétique, il n'y a pas de liberté ici. C'est la seule façon d'obtenir cette matrice en prenant une combinaison linéaire des matrices de Pauli. C'est
parce que les matrices de Pauli incluant la matrice identité forment une base pour l'espace vectoriel de toutes les matrices 2x2. Une façon
de vérifier l'exactitude de cette expression est d'utiliser certaines identités trigonométriques de base, et en particulier si je m'écarte un instant,
voici quelques identités qui feront l'affaire. Donc si tu en as envie, mets la vidéo en pause ou
prends une capture d'écran et vois si tu peux obtenir la deuxième expression de la matrice densité en bas à partir de la première. Donc en résumé, tout état pur d'un
qubit exprimé comme matrice densité peut être écrit comme une combinaison linéaire de matrices de Pauli, comme montré à l'
WEBVTT
écran, pour theta entre 0 et pi et phi entre 0 et 2 pi. Remarque qu'on a précisément la
même dégénérescence qu'avant, à savoir que phi est non pertinent quand theta est soit zéro soit pi. Et cette fois, on peut
le voir plus clairement parce que le sinus de theta est zéro dans ces deux cas, et sinon il ne l'est pas. Il vaut la peine de noter
que dans cette formule, theta apparaît comme argument des fonctions sinus et cosinus plutôt que theta sur 2 comme dans la version
originale avec le vecteur d'état quantique, et c'est parce qu'on a utilisé ces identités trigonométriques, dont les trois premières sont essentiellement
des réarrangements des formules dites de duplication de l'angle. Donc l'angle est effectivement doublé. Et maintenant, on est enfin prêt à
parler de la sphère de Bloch elle-même. Concentrons-nous sur les trois coefficients des matrices de Pauli non-identité
au numérateur de l'expression de notre matrice densité. On ignore donc le deux au
dénominateur. On ignore aussi la matrice identité parce que son coefficient ne change jamais. Ça se passe parce que
ce coefficient est déterminé par la trace de quelle que soit la matrice qu'on exprime, et les matrices densité ont toujours une trace égale
à un. Maintenant, imagine qu'on a trois axes étiquetés x, y et z, orientés selon
la règle de la main droite. Considère le point dont les coordonnées correspondent aux trois coefficients. Et pour être clair,
on parle d'un espace tridimensionnel ordinaire où les coordonnées sont toujours des nombres réels. La
coordonnée x correspond au coefficient de la matrice de Pauli sigma x au numérateur de notre expression, qui est toujours un nombre réel parce que les matrices
densité sont hermitiennes. De même pour y et z. Ce qu'on trouve, c'est que ce point qu'on
obtient est toujours sur la sphère unité, c'est-à-dire la sphère ayant un rayon égal à
un. En particulier, c'est le point qu'on obtient si on commence au point où l'axe z positif intersecte la sphère,
ce qu'on peut considérer comme le Pôle Nord, qu'on tourne vers le bas en direction de l'axe x positif d'un angle theta, puis
qu'on tourne vers l'axe y positif, c'est-à-dire vers l'Est, d'un angle phi. Dans ce contexte, l'angle theta est
appelé l'angle polaire, ce qui est facile à retenir parce qu'il commence au pôle. Et phi est appelé l'angle
azimutal. Ensemble, ces deux angles représentent des coordonnées sphériques pour les points sur la sphère unité. Et si tu
le voulais, tu pourrais aussi permettre au rayon de varier pour représenter des points arbitraires dans l'espace tridimensionnel, mais ici on se concentre sur les points sur la
sphère unité où le rayon est égal à un. Tu peux aussi penser à theta comme représentant la latitude, sauf qu'on va
de 0 à 180° du Pôle Nord au Pôle Sud plutôt que plus ou moins 90° depuis l'équateur. Et phi représente
la longitude, où on définit essentiellement le méridien d'origine comme étant le méridien qui intersecte l'axe x
positif. Si tu es comme moi d'ailleurs, et que tu as du mal à te rappeler lequel est la latitude et lequel est la longitude, il peut être utile de te souvenir
que la longitude correspond à l'intervalle qui est plus long : 2 pi par opposition à
pi. Quoi qu'il en soit, le point qu'on obtient sur la sphère unité à partir de notre vecteur d'état qubit psi en pensant aux coordonnées de cette
façon est la représentation sur la sphère de Bloch de l'état quantique correspondant à psi. Et quand on pense à l'ensemble de la
sphère unité tridimensionnelle de cette façon, on obtient la sphère de Bloch. Géométriquement, c'est juste une sphère unité
dans un espace tridimensionnel ordinaire. Mais en fait, c'est la géométrie des états d'un
qubit. Il y a ici une correspondance parfaite un à un : chaque état pur d'un qubit correspond à un point unique sur
la sphère, et chaque point sur la sphère représente un état unique de qubit à une phase globale près. Quand on travaille avec des
vecteurs d'état quantique. Cette correspondance porte d'autres noms d'ailleurs ; elle est aussi parfois appelée la sphère de Poincaré, par
exemple, mais dans le contexte de l'information quantique, on l'appelle généralement la sphère de Bloch. Remarque qu'on peut maintenant voir la
dégénérescence dans l'angle phi assez clairement, parce que la longitude n'a pas de signification aux Pôles Nord et Sud. Mais à part
les pôles, chaque point sur la Terre a des coordonnées uniques en termes de latitude et de longitude, et la même chose se passe ici. C'est donc ainsi que
la sphère de Bloch fonctionne en général. Regardons maintenant quelques exemples spécifiques d'états de qubit et
où ils se trouvent sur la sphère de Bloch. Commençons par la base standard. Ce sont les points qu'on obtient
quand l'angle polaire theta est zéro pour l'état zéro et pi pour l'état un. Ce sont les deux cas où l'angle
azimutal phi est non pertinent, comme je l'ai déjà discuté. On peut aussi exprimer les matrices densité correspondantes comme combinaisons linéaires
de matrices de Pauli. Dans les deux cas, on conclut que ces deux états correspondent au Pôle Nord et au
Pôle Sud de la sphère de Bloch. L'état zéro est en haut et l'état un est en
bas. Ensuite, trouvons les états plus et moins sur la sphère de Bloch. Encore une fois, on peut penser en termes de
vecteurs d'état quantique ou de matrices densité. Pour les vecteurs d'état quantique, cette fois l'angle polaire theta doit être pi
sur 2 pour que l'entrée zéro soit 1 sur racine de 2. L'angle azimutal phi doit être zéro
pour l'état plus parce que l'entrée un est positive pour l'état plus, et il doit être pi ou 180° pour l'état moins
parce que cette entrée est négative dans ce cas. Donc ces deux points se trouvent sur
l'équateur de la sphère de Bloch. L'état plus est là où l'axe x positif intersecte la sphère, et l'état moins est sur le côté opposé où l'
axe x négatif intersecte la sphère. On peut aussi voir ça de façon équivalente à partir des expressions en matrices de Pauli pour les
matrices densité correspondantes : les coordonnées y et z sont toutes les deux zéro, tandis que les coordonnées x sont positive et négative
1. Un autre exemple est la base plus i, moins i, qui est similaire à la base plus, moins, sauf qu'on multiplie aussi l'entrée
un par i, l'unité imaginaire. On a vu l'état plus i plus tôt dans la leçon, et l'état moins i est défini
de façon analogue. L'angle polaire theta est le même qu'il était pour les états plus et moins : pi sur
2. Et cette fois, on doit choisir l'angle azimutal phi de façon à obtenir i et moins i plutôt que 1 et moins 1.
Pi sur 2 et 3 pi sur 2 sont les bons choix pour faire ça. On peut aussi examiner
les descriptions en matrice densité de ces états, et les choses sont assez similaires aux deux exemples précédents, sauf que cette fois c'est la matrice de Pauli y à la place
de z ou x. Donc sur la sphère de Bloch, ces deux états se trouvent là où l'axe y
intersecte la sphère. Et si on nettoie un peu les choses, on peut voir plus clairement comment les six états qu'on vient de discuter
se rapportent les uns aux autres. Pour juste un autre exemple, ou vraiment une classe d'exemples, considère les
vecteurs d'état qubit qui sont apparus plus tôt et dans la Leçon 4, où l'entrée zéro est cosinus de alpha pour un certain nombre réel alpha et l'entrée un
WEBVTT
est le sinus de alpha. On peut d'ailleurs restreindre notre attention aux valeurs de alpha entre zéro et pi, parce que n'importe quelle
autre valeur de alpha nous donnera un vecteur qui est équivalent à une phase globale près à un vecteur où alpha est dans cet
intervalle. Si on calcule les matrices densité associées à ces états, exprimées comme combinaisons linéaires de matrices de Pauli,
on obtient l'expression montrée ici à l'écran. Ce calcul n'est pas montré ici, mais c'est ce qu'on devrait
obtenir si on le fait. Et ce qu'on trouve, c'est que ces états forment ce qu'on appelle un grand cercle qui passe
par les pôles. Plus précisément, en commençant au Pôle Nord quand alpha est zéro, en descendant le méridien d'origine et
en atteignant le Pôle Sud quand alpha est pi sur 2, puis en revenant au Pôle Nord de l'autre côté de la sphère quand alpha va de pi sur 2 à
pi. Et tout ça a du sens parce que, premièrement, ce sont des vecteurs réels, donc la partie imaginaire est toujours zéro, et deuxièmement
l'angle alpha est effectivement doublé sur la sphère de Bloch. Et encore une fois, ça peut être expliqué par l'utilisation
des formules de duplication. On a vu que la sphère de Bloch offre une très belle représentation géométrique des états purs d'un
qubit, où chaque point sur la sphère correspond à un état pur unique d'un qubit et vice
versa. Quand on parle de la boule de Bloch, on fait référence à tous les points sur la sphère de Bloch ainsi qu'aux points
contenus à l'intérieur. Les points à l'intérieur de la boule de Bloch correspondent aussi à des états de qubit,
spécifiquement des états qui ne sont pas des états purs. En d'autres termes, ce sont des états de qubit qui peuvent être représentés par des matrices densité mais pas par des vecteurs d'état de qubit.
Un aspect fondamental de la boule de Bloch et de la façon dont les points intérieurs représentent les états non purs est que
les combinaisons convexes de points à l'intérieur de la boule de Bloch correspondent aux combinaisons convexes de matrices densité.
Intuitivement, cela signifie que la géométrie continue de fonctionner parfaitement même à l'intérieur de la boule de
Bloch. Regardons quelques exemples, en commençant par le point central de la boule de Bloch, qui représente l'état
complètement mélangé. L'état complètement mélangé est obtenu en faisant la moyenne des états zéro et un, ce qui est cohérent avec le fait
que le centre de la sphère est exactement à mi-chemin entre le Pôle Nord et le Pôle Sud. Et en fait, il est à mi-chemin entre n'importe quels deux points antipodaux, comme
les états plus et moins et les états plus i et moins i. Les points antipodaux sur la sphère de Bloch correspondent toujours à
des états purs orthogonaux, et ce que ça révèle ou reflète, c'est qu'on peut toujours écrire l'état complètement mélangé
comme la moyenne entre deux états purs de qubit orthogonaux quelconques. Une autre façon de le voir est de
penser à la représentation en matrice de Pauli de l'état complètement mélangé. Pour que ça fonctionne, on doit définir
les coefficients sur toutes les trois matrices de Pauli non-identité comme étant zéro, et donc le point correspondant à l'intérieur de
la boule de Bloch est juste au centre à l'origine. D'ailleurs, penser aux représentations en matrices de Pauli des matrices
densité comme ça rend assez clair que les combinaisons convexes de points de la boule de Bloch correspondent aux combinaisons convexes
de matrices densité. Si on prend une moyenne ou une moyenne pondérée de matrices densité et qu'on exprime tout en termes de combinaisons linéaires
de matrices de Pauli, alors bien sûr on fait juste la moyenne des points correspondants parce que tout est
linéaire dans ces trois coefficients. Pour un dernier exemple, considérons la moyenne de l'état zéro
et de l'état plus, qu'on a vu plus tôt dans la leçon. On a calculé la représentation en matrice densité, montrée à l'
écran, et on a que le point est à l'intérieur de la boule de Bloch, à mi-chemin entre l'état zéro et l'état
plus. On a aussi vu qu'on pouvait exprimer cette matrice densité d'une façon différente basée sur sa décomposition spectrale, et
encore une fois, c'est cohérent avec le diagramme et les exemples précédents. Et voilà qui conclut la
discussion de la sphère de Bloch et de la boule de Bloch. Les gens demandent souvent s'il existe une sphère de Bloch ou une boule de Bloch pour les systèmes ayant
trois ou plus d'états classiques. Et la réponse malheureuse est pas vraiment. On peut toujours penser aux
états quantiques d'un système en termes géométriques similaires à la boule de Bloch, et on obtiendra un corps convexe dans un espace vectoriel réel,
mais si on a trois ou plus d'états classiques, ce ne sera pas sphérique. Par exemple, si on a
exactement trois états classiques, ou un qutrit en abrégé, on obtiendra un corps convexe dans un espace à huit dimensions.
Mais les points extrêmes de ce corps, qui correspondent aux états quantiques purs d'un qutrit, ne seront que
de dimension quatre. Si tu peux visualiser une variété à quatre dimensions dans un espace à huit dimensions et d'une façon ou d'une autre l'envelopper pour obtenir un corps convexe,
et que tu trouves que c'est une façon utile de penser aux qutrits, tant mieux pour toi. C'est intéressant à
réfléchir, mais ce n'est pas une boule, c'est plus compliqué que ça. Dans la dernière partie de la leçon, on va brièvement discuter
de la façon dont les matrices densité fonctionnent pour plusieurs systèmes. Les matrices densité peuvent représenter des états de plusieurs systèmes, et ça
fonctionne de façon complètement analogue aux vecteurs d'état quantique. En particulier, tout comme on l'a dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information
quantique, on peut voir plusieurs systèmes ensemble comme s'ils formaient un seul système
composé. Cette fois, les lignes et les colonnes des matrices densité qui représentent des états de plusieurs systèmes sont
mises en correspondance avec le produit cartésien des ensembles d'états classiques des systèmes individuels. Par exemple, on peut considérer
des représentations en matrice densité des quatre états de Bell, qu'on obtient précisément comme on l'a fait pour les autres vecteurs d'état
quantique plus tôt dans la leçon, en multipliant les vecteurs d'état par leurs transposées conjuguées. Et les résultats sont montrés ici à l'
écran. En essence, il n'y a vraiment rien de nouveau au niveau conceptuel, bien qu'on verra dans un instant qu'il y a des choses
nouvelles qu'on peut faire avec les matrices densité pour plusieurs systèmes. Les notions d'indépendance et de
corrélations passent des vecteurs d'état quantique aux matrices densité. En particulier, on trouve que les produits tensoriels
de matrices densité représentent l'indépendance entre les systèmes. On utilise la même terminologie que
pour les vecteurs d'état quantique. Par exemple, si on a un système X préparé dans un état rho et un système Y
préparé indépendamment dans un état sigma, alors l'état de la paire XY ensemble est donné par le produit tensoriel
de rho et sigma. On appelle ça un état produit, et ça se généralise de façon naturelle à plus de deux
systèmes. Les matrices densité qui ne peuvent pas être exprimées comme des états produits représentent des corrélations entre les systèmes, et cette
partie est similaire aux vecteurs d'état quantique. Mais il s'avère qu'il y a différents types de corrélations qui peuvent apparaître quand on utilise les matrices densité, même pour
juste deux systèmes. En revanche, il n'y a vraiment qu'un seul type de corrélation qu'on peut avoir pour les vecteurs d'état quantique, et
c'est l'intrication. Autrement dit, corrélation et intrication sont synonymes pour les vecteurs d'état quantique, mais
WEBVTT
ce n'est pas vrai pour les matrices densité. Ici les choses sont plus intéressantes. Par exemple, on peut décrire
des états classiques corrélés avec des matrices densité. Voici un exemple de matrice densité représentant un bit classique aléatoire
partagé entre Alice et Bob. Ils ont toujours le même état classique, zéro ou un, et la probabilité est de
1/2 pour chacune des possibilités. Ce n'est pas un état intriqué ; l'intrication n'est pas classique, mais
c'est bien un état corrélé. Un autre exemple est connecté à la notion d'ensemble d'états quantiques,
qu'on peut considérer comme une distribution de probabilité sur un ensemble fini d'états quantiques. En particulier, imaginons qu'on ait
M matrices densité rho zéro à rho M moins 1, toutes représentant des états possibles d'un système particulier,
ainsi qu'une probabilité de tirer chacune d'elles. Si on voulait, on pourrait calculer la moyenne pondérée de ces matrices densité
en prenant une combinaison convexe d'elles, mais ça ne nous dirait pas en fait quels sont les états individuels ou quelles sont les
probabilités. Ce qu'on peut faire à la place, et c'est assez utile de le faire parfois, c'est de considérer une matrice
densité de la forme montrée ici à l'écran. C'est un état de deux systèmes où le premier système a un état classique
pour chacune des alternatives, et on prend la moyenne pondérée de M états produits où l'état du
premier système est toujours classique et étiquette essentiellement lequel des M états on a pour le deuxième
système. Si ce n'est pas clair exactement pourquoi on voudrait penser à des états comme ça, pas de problème. C'est juste un exemple de
type de corrélation où le premier système est toujours classique et le deuxième système peut être dans un état
quantique. Une troisième catégorie d'états possiblement corrélés est l'ensemble des états dits séparables.
En termes simples, ce sont des combinaisons convexes d'états produits, et ils représentent essentiellement des états quantiques
où toute corrélation entre les systèmes est une corrélation classique. Une façon de penser à
des états comme ça est qu'on fait une sélection probabiliste pour un nombre k, puis qu'on prépare indépendamment deux
systèmes dans un état quantique qui peut dépendre de ce choix de k. Ce qui est peut-être le plus intéressant dans
des états de cette forme, c'est que c'est en fait comme ça qu'on définit l'intrication en termes mathématiques. En particulier, l'intrication est
définie comme un manque de séparabilité. Donc si tu as une matrice densité et qu'il n'est pas possible de l'exprimer sous une forme
comme ça, alors par définition elle est intriquée. Je l'ai évoqué dans la Leçon 4 et voilà quelques
détails supplémentaires. D'ailleurs, il peut être très difficile de déterminer si une matrice densité donnée représente un état
intriqué, même avec l'aide d'un ordinateur. D'un point de vue mathématique et computationnel, l'intrication est
en réalité assez compliquée. J'ai mentionné au début de la leçon qu'il y a une chose très importante qu'on peut faire avec les matrices densité, et
c'est de décrire les états de parties isolées de systèmes, même quand elles sont corrélées et éventuellement intriquées avec d'autres
systèmes. Le terme état réduit est souvent utilisé dans ce contexte. Et comme exemple simple, on va calculer les états réduits
des qubits individuels qui forment un ebit. Pour être précis, supposons qu'
Alice et Bob partagent un ebit. Alice détient un qubit A, Bob détient un qubit B, et ensemble ces deux qubits sont dans un état
phi plus. Et la question qu'on va aborder est : quel est l'état du qubit A d'Alice en
isolation ? Bien sûr, on pourrait poser la même question pour le qubit de Bob, mais il est facile de répondre à cette question une fois qu'on connaît la réponse à celle-là.
Maintenant, on pourrait être tenté de dire qu'on ne peut pas décrire l'état du qubit d'Alice en isolation parce qu'il est
intriqué avec le qubit de Bob, ce qui pourrait en quelque sorte nous empêcher de décrire ou même de penser à l'état de A en
isolation. Mais c'est faux. Il est vrai qu'on ne peut pas décrire l'état de A avec un vecteur d'état
quantique parce que, comme on le verra, il n'est pas dans un état pur. Mais chaque système a un état à tout moment donné qui peut être
décrit par une matrice densité, qu'il soit intriqué avec un autre système ou non. Comme expérience de pensée, juste pour nous aider à
voir quelle est la réponse à cette question, supposons que Bob décide de prendre son qubit et de voyager vers les étoiles, et qu'on ne le réentend plus
jamais. Mais imaginons qu'en chemin, il décide d'effectuer une mesure dans la base standard sur son
qubit. Eh bien, on sait comment calculer les probabilités pour qu'il obtienne les deux résultats possibles, et on sait aussi quel sera
l'état de A pour chaque résultat possible. Et ces choses sont résumées dans ce tableau. En particulier, avec une probabilité de 1/2,
A sera laissé dans l'état zéro, et avec une probabilité de 1/2, A sera laissé dans l'état un. Et donc, comme discuté plus tôt dans
la leçon, ça laisse A dans l'état complètement mélangé, et c'est donc la réponse
à notre question. Maintenant, tu pourrais objecter et dire que ça dépend du fait que
Bob a décidé de mesurer son qubit, et que l'hypothèse qu'il fait ça fait partie de l'histoire qui nous a conduits à cette réponse. Mais
si Bob est à des années-lumière de distance au moment où il mesure, rien de ce qu'il fait ne peut éventuellement avoir d'influence sur n'importe quelle
expérience qu'Alice pourrait décider d'effectuer sur son qubit. Sinon, on aurait une communication
plus rapide que la lumière. Donc le qubit d'Alice est dans l'état complètement mélangé, que Bob mesure ou non.
Je dois préciser à ce stade que la notion d'état réduit et la façon dont il est défini n'ont pas vraiment de dépendance envers la relativité
ou l'impossibilité d'une communication plus rapide que la lumière. C'est juste une façon de l'expliquer en termes espérons-le intuitifs.
En réalité, il y a une définition mathématique qu'on verra dans un contexte plus général dans quelques instants. C'est cohérent avec cette réponse
et coïncide aussi avec l'impossibilité de communication plus rapide que la lumière. Et il n'y a pas d'autre
définition qui pourrait être cohérente avec l'information quantique telle qu'on la connaît. Considérons maintenant les états réduits dans une plus grande
généralité. Supposons qu'on ait une paire de systèmes A et B, pas nécessairement des qubits, qui sont ensemble dans un état pur
représenté par un vecteur d'état quantique psi. Encore une fois, on va se concentrer sur l'état réduit du système A. Et pour ce
faire, il va être utile de penser aux états classiques du système B. Donc soit gamma cet ensemble d'
états classiques de B. Comme on en a discuté avant, dans la leçon 2 de la série par exemple,
il y a une collection unique de vecteurs phi b pour chaque b dans gamma pour lesquels l'expression de psi montrée à l'écran
est correcte. Et en particulier, il y a une formule simple pour ces vecteurs : on multiplie simplement le vecteur psi par le
produit tensoriel de la matrice identité correspondant au système A avec bra b pour quel que soit le b qui nous intéresse.
Ce qu'on fait ici c'est essentiellement se préparer pour calculer ce qui se passerait si on effectuait une mesure dans la base standard
WEBVTT
sur B. Et encore une fois, ça a été couvert dans la leçon 2 de la
série. Supposons qu'on effectue une mesure dans la base standard sur B. Chaque résultat possible apparaîtrait alors
avec une probabilité égale à la norme euclidienne au carré du vecteur phi b correspondant. Et conditionnellement à l'obtention d'un
résultat particulier b, on normalise le vecteur phi b pour déterminer l'état résultant de
A. En suivant le même raisonnement que dans l'exemple de l'ebit de tout à l'heure, on obtient l'expression montrée à l'
écran pour l'état réduit de A comme matrice densité. D'ailleurs, la norme au carré au dénominateur provient de
la multiplication du vecteur normalisé par sa transposée conjuguée. On obtient donc la norme euclidienne deux fois au
dénominateur. Les normes euclidiennes au carré s'annulent et on se retrouve avec une expression assez simple.
Et en fait, si on substitue notre formule pour phi b, qui fonctionne pour tout b, on obtient une formule pour l'état réduit
du système A en termes de la description en matrice densité de l'état pur dont on est parti, à savoir ket psi
bra psi. C'est donc notre formule pour l'état réduit du système A, supposant que le système composé AB a commencé dans
l'état pur psi. Mais on peut aussi utiliser la formule de façon plus générale. En particulier, supposons
que l'état de AB est donné par une certaine matrice densité rho, qui pourrait prendre la forme ket psi bra psi pour un certain vecteur d'état
quantique psi, mais pas nécessairement. Il s'ensuit essentiellement par linéarité que l'état réduit de A est
déterminé par la même formule qu'on avait pour les états purs, sauf qu'on substitue quelle que soit la matrice densité rho qu'on
souhaite. Comme notation abrégée, il est assez courant qu'on désigne cet état réduit par quel que soit le nom qu'on utilise pour la
matrice densité rho dans ce cas, mais on met un indice indiquant le système sur lequel on se concentre. Donc rho avec un indice
A signifie l'état réduit de A quand le système composé est dans l'état rho. Des exposants sont aussi parfois utilisés
à la place des indices. C'est essentiellement juste une préférence personnelle et ça signifie la même
chose. On s'est concentré sur le système A juste pour simplifier, mais on peut aussi obtenir l'état réduit du système B
de façon analogue, mais où la formule est adaptée de la façon naturelle. Tout est symétrique ici. On échange essentiellement
les rôles de A et B, et en particulier la somme porte cette fois sur les états classiques de A
plutôt que de B. Et dans la formule à l'écran, on suppose que l'ensemble d'états classiques de A s'appelle
sigma. Tout ça se généralise de façon assez directe à trois systèmes ou plus. Par exemple, si on a trois
systèmes A, B et C qui sont collectivement dans l'état décrit par la matrice densité rho, alors on peut obtenir l'
état réduit de la paire A ensemble par la formule montrée ici, ainsi que l'état du troisième système seul
par la deuxième formule. Et tu peux considérer d'autres combinaisons et généraliser ça à autant de systèmes que tu veux. Les sommes sont toujours prises sur
les ensembles d'états classiques des systèmes qu'on ignore, et le schéma est toujours le même : la matrice
densité dont on est parti est encadrée entre le produit tensoriel de la matrice identité et des bras et kets correspondant aux états de base
standards. Pour conclure la leçon, je vais dire juste un peu plus sur les définitions qu'on vient de couvrir. L'opération sur les matrices
densité qui décrit les états réduits a un nom, et elle s'appelle la trace partielle. Pour deux systèmes A et B, la
trace partielle sur B et la trace partielle sur A sont définies ici à l'écran. Ce sont exactement les mêmes
formules qu'on a vues il y a quelques instants, et maintenant on les pense juste comme des fonctions de rho et on leur donne des
noms. Les noms ressemblent à la trace sauf qu'il y a un indice qui nous dit quel système est supprimé,
c'est-à-dire quel système est celui dont l'ensemble d'états classiques est celui sur lequel on somme et qui est encadré entre un bra et un
ket. Quand on prend la trace partielle sur B par exemple, ce qui est décrit par la première formule, on dit parfois que
B est tracé dehors, et de même pour A. Intuitivement, tracer dehors un
système signifie juste qu'on le jette ou qu'on l'ignore simplement. C'est une façon de définir la trace
partielle. Et une autre façon équivalente est de dire que ces applications sont les seules applications linéaires qui satisfont les
formules montrées ici à droite. Plus précisément, si on a un produit tensoriel de deux matrices M et N, disons,
et qu'on effectue la trace partielle sur le premier système, alors ce qu'on obtient est la trace de la première matrice M fois
la deuxième matrice. Et la condition est symétrique quand on trace sur le deuxième système. Toute matrice sur laquelle on calculerait la trace partielle n'est pas
un produit tensoriel comme ça, mais toute matrice peut s'exprimer comme une combinaison linéaire de
produits tensoriels, et on peut déterminer la trace partielle à partir de ces conditions ainsi que du fait que ces fonctions sont
linéaires. Et c'est pourquoi ça s'appelle la trace partielle. Cette définition équivalente peut être
assez utile parce qu'on peut souvent l'utiliser plutôt que la formule originale. Voici un exemple qui
l'illustre. Supposons qu'on ait une paire de qubits A dans l'état dont la matrice densité est montrée ici à l'
écran. C'est un exemple d'état corrélé où A est soit dans l'état zéro soit dans l'état un, chacun
avec probabilité 1/2. On peut donc penser à A comme étant classique. Si A est dans l'état zéro, alors
B l'est aussi. Et si A est dans l'état un, alors B est dans l'état plus. Si on veut savoir quel est l'état réduit de A,
on trace dehors B. Et si on utilise la deuxième formule de la définition équivalente ainsi que la linéarité, on peut
calculer ça assez facilement. En particulier, la trace de ket 0 bra 0 est un, tout comme la trace de ket plus bra
plus. Donc ces facteurs tensoriels disparaissent et on se retrouve avec l'état complètement mélangé. De façon similaire, on peut calculer
l'état réduit de B en traçant dehors A. Cette fois, c'est le premier facteur tensoriel sur lequel on effectue la trace, donc
on utilise la première formule de la définition équivalente, et on se retrouve avec 1/2 fois ket 0 bra 0 plus 1/2 fois ket
plus bra plus, ou en d'autres termes la même matrice densité qui est apparue quelques fois auparavant. On obtiendrait exactement les
mêmes résultats si tu utilisais les formules de la première définition, mais c'est une façon beaucoup plus facile de le faire. Tout ça se généralise à trois systèmes ou
WEBVTT
plus, mais pour cette vidéo, je vais m'arrêter ici et te laisser réfléchir à ça par toi-même. Et voilà pour cette leçon, qui a
introduit les matrices densité et décrit les bases de leur fonctionnement. On a aussi discuté de la sphère de Bloch,
ainsi que des différents types de corrélations et de la notion d'état réduit d'un système. J'espère que tu te joindras à moi pour la
prochaine leçon, qui porte sur les channels, qui sont des applications linéaires des matrices densité vers les matrices densité qui
décrivent des opérations sur des systèmes. À bientôt jusqu'à
là.